[Music]
like I told you from the beginning
I am the future flash
hey everybody its charlie you may have
noticed how Supergirl is borrowing a lot
from Smallville in the flash so I'll
explain all the references there most of
you have a pretty good idea of what the
TV show is doing if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the DC videos there's a new
round of the Legion ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video cursory spoiler warning for
Supergirl but there's really like three
different concepts that you need to
understand three different types of
stories to know what's going on with
Supergirl
it seems really twisty but it's not that
complicated so one you need to know a
little bit about Smallville season four
in black kryptonite with kal-el at the
beginning of the season and then with
Lex Luthor towards the end of the season
because Lina Luthor is now playing with
black kryptonite
[Music]
amazing work isn't it
hello me
meet the real you someone should tell
her to watch smallville season 4 episode
17 before she starts playing with black
kryptonite that was the episode where
Lex got separated into the evil version
of Lex Alexander Luthor in the good
version Lex if you don't remember the
evil version immediately through the
good version in prison and went on a
tear until they were able to take it
down the Supergirl side of things
obviously there was a time-travel
component they borrowed a little bit
from the flash finale to where they sort
of rewound time back like oh right this
isn't gonna work so we're just gonna use
time travel to solve our problem the
thing about the duplicate though is that
they didn't create it the same way that
Salvatore was created but black
kryptonite separates aspects of people's
personality now which aspects it
separates is up for grabs like who is
this red Sun looking Supergirl here so
that's obviously the third story that
you need to understand Superman red Sun
because of all the Russia Siberia stuff
so clearly what it seems like is gonna
happen is is this version of Supergirl
is going to be the villain of the season
for at least a little while until a
bigger threat emerges because Brainiac
is like my cousin in the future is
taking over all technology so we're all
like wait a minute is Brainiac gonna be
the villain next season because he's
doing that in the future but does that
mean that Brainiac is gonna come into
the past so it's just a question if
Brainiac 5 is gonna be a main character
during Supergirl season 4 then that
means that this version of Supergirl
probably won't wind up being the villain
the entire time it just because she is
walking into Siberia and they have this
real red Sun vibe to it doesn't
necessarily mean that she's gonna be
evil there's a weird thing with watching
melissa is an actor tried to be evil if
you watch the crossover episodes the
evil / girl version of her character
from Earth X was kind of silly like a
really good example of an evil character
performance is Tom Cavanaugh's
reverse-flash during the crossover so
watch what he does with his performance
then watch what Melissa does i watch you
die
time travel very very confusing I always
seem to be saying that do don't I on our
earth we've developed a meritocracy
we've accomplished greatness you're
perverse the whole car you're the
perversion the most powerful being on
the planet rendered weak by saccharin
Americana
Melissa's evil Supergirl is more emo
Supergirl it's like watching Barry be
emo Barry like it's not exactly what you
would expect from an evil version of
that character Melissa is just like this
very pure soul like she's a very nice
person in real life I think it's just
hard for her to play an evil character
so I don't think that this version of
Supergirl is gonna be straight up evil
like saboteur was but you had that
conversation
don't I have the right to live just as
much as you even though I was created by
this accident likes avatars whole deal
is is that everybody hated them because
they thought that he wasn't the real
Barry so that's what pitted him against
this version of Barry and set him on
this whole mission to become a God so
obviously that's not exactly what super
goes gonna do but they do have that
storyline like who has the right to live
is this version of Supergirl gonna have
to get folded back into main super girl
by the end of the season because two
halves of a whole like do you have to
combine them to create the whole by the
end of the season most black kryptonite
stories including the rain story end
with one of the versions either being
destroyed or imprisoned for all time so
like when they did it with Samantha the
demons carried her off just like at the
end of flash season 2 with the time
demons carrying black flash off so even
more flash in there but during
Smallville when Martha separated kal-el
from Clark at the beginning of season 4
with black kryptonite
Clark killed that version of kal-el so
like he killed an aspect of himself
logically that shouldn't work they kind
of did a similar thing on Rick and Morty
like the idea is is that you need that
piece of yourself because it makes you
who you are you can't just get rid of
parts of your personality oh and I think
you dropped something too
please tell me you're not trying to put
that stuff back inside of us Rudy I'm
sorry that stuff is alive and it belongs
with us we yanked them from their homes
and locked them in a can mother see
they're living in pain that's what they
do Ric they live in pain they are pain
you know they're all the bad parts of us
which by the way includes our dishonesty
so how do you know this is an awesome
sort of crazy trick oh so now because I
made entirely of toxins I'm also a liar
so there are a couple ways that they
could get rid of this other version of
Supergirl by the end of the season
without necessarily killing her but if
there's gonna be a bigger villain like
Brainiac to surface then she would
probably be the one to sacrifice herself
like once she sort of comes to terms
with the original version of Supergirl
okay yeah I'm a duplicate this world
technically belongs to you if she's not
gonna go out to some other world and be
the Supergirl of the multiverse then
she's probably gonna either have to
sacrifice herself or be folded back in
using a reverse black kryptonite twist
I think they wouldn't have put her in
Siberia though if they weren't intending
on giving her a version of the red Sun
costume but false memories black
kryptonite mind wiping is really the
only way to explain how this Supergirl
just doesn't turn right back around and
go back to the de Oh thinking that she's
the real version of Supergirl like not
knowing that she's a duplicate let me
know in the comments though do you
actually think that they're gonna do
something like that and what do you want
them to do at the end of the season with
this other version of Supergirl because
she can't continue to exist they have to
get rid of her somehow they'll be more
ant-man of the wasp posting in a little
while they just dropped some new footage
and more behind the scenes
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner ganja Soros please private
message me so I can get your contact
details yes there will be new Titans
again soon click here for more new flash
season 5 and click here for more new
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight